- I'm looking for the Trading Post.
It was my crib.
- The Trading Post was your crib.
(whimsical music)
- We are going to be logging into Neopets
for the very first time in 15 years.
- Oh my gosh, you've never
played Neopets before?
Well, let me tell you,
you were missing out,
'cause it was fun.
It had games.
- It had parenting.
- Yes.
- You have a pet, and you
play games without the pet,
and then you just buy things for this pet
who doesn't really speak, move, or talk.
- It think it was like the
first time I was really addicted
to the Internet.
- I played probably around
10 to 15 hours a week
for four to five years.
- Oh my god.
- All right, we are logging in.
My username was XXQTDANCERGIRL5678.
- TARA_IS_COOL18.
- BEAVERSXONXFIRE.
I don't know why.
- Oh my gosh.
- They have not changed a damn thing.
- It's the same fucking thing.
- My parents, like, didn't
ever want to get a pet,
so the closest thing I could
get to a pet was on Neopets.
- That was always weird.
Like, what kind of fucking
animals were these?
Like, when you look back,
this is really weird.
- The names are bomb.
The names are awesome.
I freaking love the names.
- Pixie is hungry.
I know, beotch.
Okay, how do I feed her?
- All right, now we are going to our bank.
- Oh.
My.
God.
She has 2.3 million Neopoints.
- It think Neocoins were
the precursor to Bitcoins.
- Yeah, definitely.
- Can we talk about the fact
that there's Neopin inflation rate?
There's like a real economy in here.
- Some jerk decided to
hack into my account.
He started asking me these
questions, and I answered
until I realized that he
was asking me for, like,
the answers to my recovery
password questions.
- [Guy] That's so funny. (laughter)
- When I got hacked, I was
like, I'm gonna pick myself up.
I will work twice as hard,
and I'm gonna make it big.
And I sort of did, I guess.
- I played Meerca Chase at
least a hundred times a day.
It's so addicting, 'cause you're like--
- [Guy] You know you could do better.
- You know you could do better.
You know you can do better.
- Now I'm gonna spin
the Wheel of Excitement.
It's been a long time.
- [Guy] Nooo.
(both exclaim)
- Oh, I fucking love Beach Volleyball.
Didn't make the volleyball
team in real life,
but best believe I was
killin' it with the Myncis.
- Oh.
- [Both] Kass Basher.
- [Guy] Oh my god.
- [Girl] That's the one.
- Oh, I almost died trying to talk to you.
I can't be talking to you right now.
I'm trying to play a game.
(playful music)
(both exclaim in disgust)
- So I'm gonna log you out, Inca,
'cause you're gonna play this forever.
'Cause we awakened the Beast.
- I'm, like, smiling a lot right now,
'cause it just reminds me
of so many--
- Yeah.
- Like, happy memories of
me enjoying my Neopets.
- Neopets is part of who I am, okay?
Neopets made me into what I am today.
(laughter)
- You so felt like you
were going to get a burrito
at the snack shop.
- Oh yeah.
- Or you were going to invest your money
into the stock market.
- Oh yeah.
- This was Me Time, me and my Neopets,
just exploring this world on our own.
It's us against the world, like.
No, no regrets at all.
It was so fun.
- I miss Neopets a lot.
Like, I think it's great.
It was a safe space for
me until I got hacked.
(laughter)
- That's a lot.
- So, no, that's very little.
Did you see how much money I had?
- Okay.
All right.
(girl laughs)
- [Girl] I'm probably
never gonna log in again.